home again is directed by Haley Myers
Shire daughter of Charles Shire and
Nancy Meyers two gigantic big rom-com
directors and writers that have been
working for decades in the industry and
have made tons of classic romantic
comedies and it stars Reese Witherspoon
before I get into my review I have to
tell you exactly what happened before I
saw the film I walked up the ticket
counter and I said one for home again
please and he rang me up and he handed
me the ticket and he said just let you
know it's really crowded in there you
know good luck finding a seat
and I was like really a lot of people
are coming to see home again
and he went wait what and I looked at my
ticket and he had rang me up a ticket
for Stephen King's it he legitimately
thought I was joking when I said home
again and he just gave me a ticket to it
and I was like no I actually really
wanted to see I was gonna go see home
again like it's what I'm that's what I'm
here for
he was like oh I'm sorry so that started
out the night interestingly Reese
Witherspoon plays a recently separated
mother of two daughters who allows three
young filmmaker men to move in with her
because I guess she thinks that would be
an interesting change of pace and maybe
her daughters will have fun with three
random strange men and that's the plot
of the movie as I said it's written and
directed by Haley Myers shyer daughter
of two extremely successful romantic
comedy filmmakers who have been working
for a really long time and before I get
into my review I feel the need to let
you know that I am actually a fan of
romantic comedies if they're good I have
a soft spot for a good one I like the
intern the father of the bride movies
I liked something's gotta give these are
all Nancy Meyers productions and it has
every box checked off in the
prerequisite Myers romantic comedy
checklist including a big a-list star
like Reese Witherspoon a bunch of really
privileged people who are extremely rich
and entitled and yet you rarely ever
actually see them working and when they
are working it's usually at home like on
a couch and they're really frustrated
and there's some romantic tension as
well I was hoping I wouldn't have to say
the
I was hoping it wouldn't have to go
there in this review but this is one of
the worst romantic comedies I've seen in
a very long time because it tries to go
for such a false sense of liftman and
happiness and entitlement and it rings
so hollow and so false throughout the
entire runtime that it feels almost
worse than if the movie was just this
disaster and everything failed because
Reese Witherspoon is giving a adorably
awkward performance as usual Dean Cundy
is the cinematographer legendary Back to
the Future Jurassic Park who in his
later years has taken to lensing films
like Jack and Jill for some reason here
his cinematography is very glossy and it
just does not look real go back and
watch like father of the bride with
Steve Martin and it actually looks like
real people in a real environment and
when you look at films like this
nowadays everything just looks so
perfectly lit and glossy and fake that
it just looks artificial what could have
been an interesting play on gender roles
between men and women just becomes
another awkward movie where one of them
sort of likes her and they're gonna
maybe sleep together and then things
will get really awkward when her ex
shows up and it's just all of the
cliches ticked off every other scene and
it's really disappointing because the
idea of this premise three guys who are
just trying to make it in Hollywood
moving in with someone who knows people
who did make it in Hollywood which by
the way just is very very meta Reese
Witherspoon plays the daughter of a very
famous filmmaker so at some point you
have to wonder how much of this is Haley
Myers shyer playing herself writing
herself and how much of it is this
fantasy romantic comedy that I was
watching one of the worst parts about
this movie is that it falls into that
trap that most romantic comedies do for
maybe one scene and that is having
really long and awkward montages of
people laughing or reacting or talking
or telling a joke with all of the audio
drowned out and you just get music there
are I believe at least four
of those in this movie you could make
like a five to six minutes super cut of
scenes that people just going
[Music]
and in typical rom-com format every
single main character goes through the
low part of their arc where they're
depressed and angry at the exact same
time despite being separated the
dialogue in this script feels like first
draft dialogue like there's still five
or six more passes to go I wrote down
some of it for you 27 year olds just
screw up they just do I know this
because I used to be one then like ten
seconds later she says I know this
because I know this you know what the
difference between men and women is men
just do things women have to make lists
and plan but not you you're one of the
good ones you're like a woman you
deserve better than me and I don't mean
that like most guys mean it when they
don't actually mean it I really do if
you take a chance on us there's like an
80% chance that we will not let you down
even the little girl in the film Reese
Witherspoon's daughter has this big
speech planned that she has to get ready
for and she wants one of these guys
who's a writer to stand backstage to
give her moral support and of course
everyone's trying to converge and run to
this speech to get there on time because
you don't want to be late we have to
have a big action scene at the end like
an airport or get to a taxi or whatever
that all these movies have but she can't
even get her lines out until she sees
the guy standing there it's like she
couldn't do it on her own she had to
have this random stranger who's been
staying in her house show up to go and
then she was fine that's the type of
film we are watching here guys it's
essentially a fantasy
it's a fantasy this is one of the worst
romantic comedies I've ever seen as a
debut it's very troubling and I can only
hope that in the future Haley Myers
Shire can perhaps find her own voice and
make a film that isn't essentially a
tired remake of one of her mother's
films I'm gonna give home again addy
guys thank you very much as always for
watching look forward to more reviews
very soon and if you like this you can
click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]